the problem is now that we're so
dependent on GPS that we never learned
I've lived in Nashville for 2 years and
I still I'm ashamed to say hardly know
how to get around because I always use
the GPS is that is that a bad thing to
not know how to get around right yeah
you're relying on GPS I think it's a bad
thing yeah really for me it's I'm able
to put on the GPS and mentally I could
be somewhere else not having to pay
attention to directions but I could
think in my mind of different ideas or
different instead of like what street is
this am I going to pass it it it takes
away my mental energy on navigating when
I could rely on something like GPS yeah
but I think that's a bad thing because
that's it's exact that's exactly the
problem you're not inhabiting the
current moment your thought is always
somewhere else in the future or you're
looking at your phone and doing
something else you know you're on
Twitter or something while you're
driving not that I would ever do that I
think it's good to actually like okay
I'm driving this is what I'm doing I'm
going from here to there you're you you
are aware of the present moment you're
inhabiting it and going from point A to
point B